-You mentioned New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo --
this is someone you've covered
for 20 years.
I think a lot of people
became introduced to him
based on his early
coronavirus press conferences,
for which he was praised
for maybe being
a little bit more
straight-talking
than the president.
Are you surprised now
at the place he's in?
Obviously,
we're hearing a lot about,
you know,
him covering up the accoun
of exactly how many people
passed away in nursing homes
as well as allegations
of sexual harassment.
-Well, look,
I'm always surprised
when politicians behave
inappropriately or stupidly,
but, no, not particularly.
I mean, anybody who's been
familiar with Andrew Cuomo
is familiar
with the fact that --
well, first of all,
when it comes to, you know
accusations of him
being abrasive or bullying
that's just been his way
the whole time
I've been aware of him.
I mean, I remember in 2002
covering his gubernatorial run
he withdrew before he got --
he would have been shellacke
in the Democratic primary
by Carl McCall,
who went on to get
the nomination
and then lose to
Governor Pataki.
And I don't know that he -
remember, he was a HUD --
he was Secretary
of the Department of Housing
and Urban Development
during the Clinton
administration.
I'm not sure that anybody else
from the Clinton administratio
endorsed him,
even though he had worked
in the Clinton administration.
And, look, he has a long -
has had a reputation
for being bullying,
and so, no, this isn't -- this
isn't particularly surprising.
I am surprised by the covering
up of the nursing-home data,
because, as always, it's not
the crime, it's the cover-up
What -- you know,
what he did with
the nursing home is certainly --
nursing homes,
forcing them to take in people
even if they have COVID,
you know,
was a very questionable
decision.
But then covering up the data --
that's really the kind of thin
that gets somebody in trouble.
-And based on the fact,
you know, now he's said that
he unintentionally
made women feel uncomfortable,
he's apologized for that -
it seems like he is trying
to move on from it.
Do you think this is something
that he gets through
and survives politically?
-Well, I mean,
he seems to be doing
the Governor Ralph Northam
approach --
remember him from Virginia -
he had the blackface
controversy.
And he ignored all the calls
for his resignation,
and he basically survived.
Maybe it's
the Donald Trump approach.
People thought he should
withdraw from the --
when he was --
after the "Access Hollywood"
video came out,
people said he should withdraw
and he ended up
being elected president.
So, I don't know.
I mean, I guess it really --
having talked to some members,
some Democratic members
of Congress
who are critical of him
but have not called
for his resignation,
I think
it really depends on what
the New York Attorney Genera
Letitia James
finds in her investigation
Because, if there is more,
or if she comes out and says
"Governor Cuomo sexually
harassed these two women,"
then, that's gonna be toug
for him,
but we'll have to see.
I think a lot of people
are punting
and waiting to see what
that investigation entails
-Last thing
I want to ask you about --
you wrote a political thriller
called "The Hellfire Club,
and now you have a sequel coming
out in a couple of months.
-I do.
-Has it been nice
to have something fictional,
albeit one that is inspire
by historical events,
to sort of find solace in
during these trying times?
-Yeah. I wrote a lot of it
during the pandemic last yea
when I didn't have a commute
because I was broadcasting
from my house.
So, from April to July, I mean
I just didn't have two hours
in a car every day,
then I suddenly had some time.
And, yeah,
it takes place in 1962.
The main characters
from the first book,
Charlie and Margaret,
go and investigate
Sinatra and the Rat Pack.
They're blackmailed
by Attorney General Kennedy.
So, yeah, that was a lot of fu
to just, like, plunge into
1962 Hollywood in Los Angeles,
in that whole world of Hitchcock
and John Frankenheimer
and Marilyn Monroe,
and that was --
yes, to not pay attention
to the dystopia that
we lived through last summer -
that was --
that was miserable --
kids being schooled at home,
angry -- angry friends
and family members,
and President Trump doing
everything he did --
we don't have to
go back into that.
Yeah, it was nice to spend
some time with the Rat Pack.
-Well, hopefully, we'll ge
you back in a couple of months
to talk about your book
when it comes out.
Thanks so much for making time
for us today, Jake.
-Thanks, Seth.
Love to Lexi.